[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo l'émission qui revient
chaque semaine sur les temps forts de
l'actualité à l'assemblée et au sénat
est avec moi pour présenter cette
émission steve jourdain bonjour style
bonjour brigitte est notre invité
aujourd'hui c'est un cheat tu es mal
bonjour a chuté mal vous êtes sénateur
socialiste du val d'oise et c'est steve
qui dresse votre portrait racheter mal
vous êtes né à eaubonne dans le val
d'oise c'est dans ce département que
vous avez fait vos premières armes en
politique votre maison c'est le parti
socialiste secrétaire de section premier
fédéral secrétaire national à partir de
2014 premier secrétaire par intérim en
2007 2017 c'est une mauvaise année un
pour le parti socialiste mais plutôt une
bonne année pour vous puisque mois
d'octobre vous êtes élu sénateur
les élections c'est un peu votre domaine
d'expertisé vous avez été secrétaire
adjoint aux élections au sein du ps et
vous n'aimez pas qu'on dise en parlant
des dernières municipales qu'on a
assisté à une vague verte pourquoi c'est
pas que j'aime ou j'aime pas la
politique s'est passé il ya des faits il
ya une progression et moi je suis
heureux que quand des partenaires
progresse il ya une progression
manif est notable et sensible d'europe
écologie les verts
et après il faut regarder la réalité de
l'ensemble municipal aujourd'hui si on
prend la gauche le premier réseau d'élu
local et de très très très très loin
c'est le parti sa liste donc le paralyse
depuis 2014 ces dernières élections nous
avons progressé dans mon département par
exemple est donc partout et je pourrais
citer beaucoup de gens je à michaël
delafosse à montpellier mathieu klein à
nancy et je prends dans le lit de france
vous avez par exemple karim - bram à
saint-ouen mais il même mathieu hanotin
à saint denis en a déjà zaz à châtillon
belle victoire et puis dans mon
département d'esprit de morat a besoin
je vous en citer beaucoup d'autres donc
à une nouvelle génération qui arrive et
je faisais une bonne chose
voilà donc moi je faisais pas d'accord
avec olivier forges pour vous c'est il
est hors de question de se mettre à la
remorque des écologistes pour les envies
des prochaines élections
avant mon positionnement n'est pas par
rapport à untel ou untel je respecte
j'ai beaucoup d'amitié pour les premiers
secrétaires du personnel et je dis
simplement que l'élection de la
prochaine élection présidentielle elle
sera très important notre pays et je
crois que les socialistes mais il faut
renouveler notre pensée il faut un
projet socialiste et je vous présente et
donc forcément j'ai derrière un candidat
sociale écologiste
me dit olivier faure moi je ne sais pas
ce qu'est la social-écologie jusqu'à
preuve du contraire par socialiste est
un parti europe ecologie qu'il faut un
candidat social moi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui je pense qu'aujourd'hui
les verts et apporte une réponse
partielle à son de problématiques et je
crois que nous socialistes avant de
réponse plus globale il faut réinventer
faut un nouveau projet socialiste pour
la france et après on discutera que les
partenaires et moi je pense que si je
t'assure avec les plagistes
si je pensais que ce que propose
socialiste était plus opérants que ce
qu'est la social démocratie
je serai chez les verts je suis
socialiste parce que je pense que la
question d'égalité la question sociale
la question de l'émancipation la laïcité
etc et mis une priorité majeure dont je
suis socialiste et je pense que ce
projet-là correspond mieux aux français
qu'un autre projet ça me semble juste
cohérent et je crois que je crois quand
vous êtes militant d'un parti politique
peut le comprendre
sinon avec les socialistes et
écologistes à vos plats bas donc moi je
le pense qu'il faut faire paraître à
première chose c'est un projet
socialiste parce que je pense qu'il faut
je pense qu'on présente aux français ce
qui est notre vision pour la france pour
le monde pour l'europe
ça c'est le premier point après s'il ya
une primaire de la gauche
faisons là mais sinon s'il n'y a pas de
primaire s'il n'y a pas que les
socialistes qu'elle serait donc la forme
et à méthode pour désigner un candidat
et un projet oui moi j'essaie d'être
cohérent et moi-même allé tout de suite
les titres de cette émission la
commission d' enquête parlementaire sur
la gestion de l'épidémie de kovy 19 a
pris une tournure plus politique cette
semaine à l'assemblée agnès buzyn
répondu aux tirs nourris des députés
redistribuer les pouvoirs renforcés des
collectivités locales
l'arche a présenté les 50 propositions
du sénat pour une nouvelle génération de
la décentralisation fin de la technique
de la clé d'étranglement à partir du 1er
septembre pourquoi christophe castaner
at il décidé d'y mettre fin le directeur
général de la police a répondu aux
questions des sénateurs
on l'entendra allez on commence cette
émission avec la commission d' enquête
sur la gestion de l'épidémie de
coronavirus à l'assemblée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après les experts les politiques étaient
auditionnés cette semaine par la
commission d' enquête sur la gestion de
la crise du coc vide 4 ministre de la
santé se sont succédé mais cette année
ce butin qui a eu le plus de mal à
convaincre les députés
nathalie gloire je le jure c'est sur un
ton solennel kennis busan se défend face
aux députés au coeur du débat la
question de la gestion des masques
durant son audition l'ancien ministre de
la santé affirme avoir anticipé la crise
mais la connaissance exacte des stocks
elle estime que ce n'est pas de sa
responsabilité en réalité je n'ai pas à
savoir la quantité ni disponible ni
nécessaire des dizaines voire centaines
de produits gérés en réponse aux risques
sanitaires parce que ils sont
extrêmement nombreux une version moins
de convaincre ses prédécesseurs ils sont
trois anciens ministres de la santé à
avoir été auditionné cette semaine et
tous estiment qu'assez de fonctions ils
sont responsables de tout depuis la loi
de 2007 c'est au ministre ou à son
représentant de s'assurer justement que
le nombre de matches que ce sera
suffisant
évidemment une ministre ne va pas
compter les ampoules mais une ministre
elle marque des orientations
elle prend des arbitrages et elle est
amenée à certains moments à poser des
questions et à regarder sur certains
sujets qui lui sont posées quelle est la
position telle prendre est-ce que
ministre c'est être au courant de tout
oui oui c'est être au courant de tout et
si on n'est pas au courant de quelque
chose s'arranger pour le savoir qui des
auditions qui ont mis en difficulté le
discours tenu par agnès buzyn lors de
son audition à tous à leur façon en
souligner les failles de la gestion de
crise notamment concernant les maths
karachi tu es mal est-ce que vous avez
été convaincu par agnès buzyn non je
veux dire la crise agnès b il ya deux
choses
elle c'est eux j'allais dire elle a fait
l'interview dans le monde qui était
catastrophique où allah comme dit des
choses un vrai sens
blâme pour une ancienne ministre de la
santé et puis devant les députés elle a
donné le sentiment d dans l'auto
satisfecit
c'est assez bizarre mais là pas
suffisamment préparé la france n'avait
pas été convaincu quant à lui expliqué
qu'elle avait été une des premières à
alerter par rapport aux autres pays
européens
je ne comprends pas c'est qu'elle ce
qu'elle nous dit d'un côté j'ai informé
le président pi a pas eu de réaction
quand on les français voient ce qui
s'est passé sur la première vague les
morts les difficultés un pays à l'arrêt
et puis tout ça faut pas oublier il ya
une note de monsieur salomon qui en 2016
midi s'est dit que la france n'est pas
prête à un événement de cette nature là
la question c'est qui s'est passé
pendant trois ans que s'est passé
pendant trois ans est ce qu'à un
ministre tout savoir on parle des
rapports entre politique de
l'administration
elle avait souvent relancer enfin remis
la balle dans le camp de
l'administration selon vous est ce
qu'elle est leur rôle d'un ministre ce
qu'elle pense quand on est ministre
comme zemma sur le touraine à la fin
donne des orientations mais on doit
également impulsé en temps doit avoir
une capacité de direction et de diriger
et surtout d'assumer mise je crois qu'un
siad combien il ya de masques à un
instant t
en france sur vous en tout cas quand
vous êtes sur des sujets aussi
importants qui est est ce que la france
et préparer un événement de cette nature
je crois que vous avez un cabinet vous
avez administration mais en
responsabilité c'est le ministre qui est
responsable
et quand on voit ce qu'on voit on a eu
droit parce que il faut se souvenir du
début de la crise où les gens d'aller om
était plutôt en train d'expliquer que
c'est la faute également précédent comme
à chaque fois d'ailleurs dès que c'est
jamais de leur faute
bien sûr qu'on se rend compte patatras
que finalement c'est un peu de la faute
et qui a eu des soucis effectivement
acceptation et moi je pense qu'en plus
il faut être un exercice de transparence
on le doit je pense aux français était
plus encore à ce qu'on est et ont connu
la maladie
les familles qu'on était que sont
décédés mais moi mon objectif d'une
commission enquête j'ai demandé celle au
sénat c'est la faire comprendre ce qui
s'est passé
et puis aussi préparer la france bleu la
france se dire dorénavant quand il ya un
incident à ce qu'on appelle un signe au
fait un signal faible dans un pays
comment la france est en capacité à
détecter de prendre des modèles et de
prendre les progrès les premières
disputes les commissions d'enquêté quand
vous voyez là les ministres qui se
renvoient finalement les responsabilités
est-ce que ça n'affaiblit pas l'ensemble
du monde politique bassana faiblit pas
personne n'est responsable final si
forcément des responsabilités
il faudra les pointes et puis après tout
cette commission denquête elle a pour
but de désigner des coupables
c'est pas désignés coupables ces deux
dans un premier temps de désigner est ce
qu'il ya eu des dispositifs des choses
des failles des défaillances
la réponse est oui d'ailleurs le prise
en lumière la réplique lui même l'a dit
dans une intervention il faut quand vous
pointer les défaillances il ya des
responsables mais une fois que vous avez
dit ça la question c'est comment on fait
en sorte qu'on n'ait plus à l'avenir
vous parliez réciter mal de la
commission denquête au sénat quelle est
la différence entre la commission
denquête au sénat qui va qui va faire sa
première audition la semaine prochaine
et la commission à l'assemblée nationale
bon allez c'est là se dérouler on verra
à la fin ne sais pas mais surtout de
méthode
alain milon le président de la
commission des affaires sociales et qui
va présider cette commission denquête
parle de dépassionner les débats c'est
possible pour un sujet aussi sensible
moi je pense que il faut dépassionner
mais des phases des passionnés en étant
en rigoureux et je voulais dit en
pointant ce qui n'a pas fonctionné et le
pourquoi et en préparant la france mieux
à de nouvelles méthodes et un risque
nouveau je pense c'est qu'il faut porter
mes jours j'ai la faiblesse de penser
alors je suis dans la maison à la
semaine nationale mais je sais qu'au
sénat ya aussi une très très grande
rigueur et je crois que notamment sur l'
affaire pénale art il ya une petite
différence parce que d'un côté vous avez
une majorité qui est celle du présent un
public ici à l'assemblée
et puis l'autre côté vous avez aussi des
gens qui sont pas attachées aux prêts
aux pays qui peuvent peut-être
travailler avec un peu plus de liberté
mais moi je respecte et 2 commission
denquête il ya deux champs chacun peut
aller un peu plus loin mettre en exergue
tel ou tel point moi je pense que c'est
ça la démocratie
je voudrais vous faire réaliser à
roselyne bachelot ministre de la santé
de 2007 à 2010 elle a porté une attaque
contre tout ce qu'ils attendent tous
deux laitages propose de l'écouter
j'ai entendu un représentant d'un
syndicat de médecins à dire nous
n'avions pas de masque dans nos cabinets
mais enfin des médecins qui n'ont pas de
masque dans leurs cabinets qui se
constitue pas un stock
nous n'avions pas de blouse m'enfin
pourquoi les médecins ne porte plus de
blues
qu'est ce que c'est que cette danse pays
de pasteur qu'est ce que c'est que cette
médecine
on attend que le préfet ou le directeur
de la rs viennent avec une petite
charrette porter des masques
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce pays est
infantilisé il faut quand même un peu se
prendre en main dans ce pays
c'est ça la leçon qu'il faut tirer
l'état ne peut pas tout comme disait
lionel jospin mais ce que les français
attendent tout l'état bon là vous avez
un show de
bachelet moi ce que je sais c'est au
pardon ce que je sais c'est que je
prends le cas du val d'oise - je note
que les médecins les personnels
hospitaliers ont fait beaucoup et ils
ont parfois été abandonné mais je ne
crois pas que ce qu'elles disent sous
entendu ils étaient tous à franciser non
ils ont aussi beaucoup travaillé et je
pense qu'il faut aussi faire attention à
ce qu'on dit elle a voulu faire un bon
mot je crois qu'il moi je savais plus
tôt les personnes de santé n'est pas que
seulement aussi vous avez les caissières
au tout ce qu'ils ont qui ont pendant
des mois ou des semaines et des semaines
pris beaucoup de risques pour notre
santé et pour notre façon de vivre et je
crois qu'au plus tôt les saluer allez on
poursuit cette émission avec le plan de
décentralisation présenté par le
président du sénat pour une nouvelle
génération de la décentralisation la
mission est ambitieuse et propositions
sont nombreuses 50 au total
gérard larcher a présenté la vision du
sénat pour une réorganisation de l'état
regarder ce sujet les signer jonathan du
ps sur la décentralisation le sénat
entend montrer la voie face à la presse
gérard larcher a défendu les 50 mesures
de la chambre haute pour redéfinir
l'équilibré des pouvoirs dans le pays
emmanuel macron avait sollicité le sénat
début juin pour contribuer à sa
réflexion sur l'après président autre
chose je vais renverser la table
eh ben nous lui disons moi je lui dis
politiquement chiche
et donc nous sommes dans une attitude
positive attentif en même temps
exigeante et je dis chiche
les sénateurs veulent en finir avec la
gouvernance verticale et l'hyper
centralisation à la française un
cocktail responsable selon eux de
nombreux dysfonctionnements dans la
gestion de la crise sanitaire les
collectivités étaient plus rapides plus
agile plus réactives pour apporter des
solutions besoin bien tirerons les
enseignements de cette crise et
équilibrons les pouvoirs dans notre pays
en permettant aux collectivités de faire
ce que l'état n'a pas su faire ou ne
sait pas faire
les parlementaires proposent ainsi de
délégués de nouvelles compétences aux
collectivités en matière d'emploi ou de
santé notamment
il propose par exemple de soumettre les
ars à l'autorité des régions les
sénateurs pour
post aussi d'inscrire dans la
constitution le principe du qui paie
décide pour assurer aux collectivités
leur autonomie financière
autre préconisation l'inscription dans
la constitution de l'ensemble des
compétences des maires des annonces
ciblées à destination des élus locaux
à quelques semaines des sénatoriales
c'est très bien qu'il en soit ainsi et
c'est attendu et on attend que le sénat
soit force de proposition ces pistes ont
été remises dans la foulée au président
de la république et se traduiront en
plusieurs propositions de loi dans le
courant du mois de juillet rachid tu es
mal ses cinquante propositions ce sont
les propositions de gérard larcher du
sénat ou de la majorité sénatoriale
d'abord il faut savoir que pour les
socialistes au sénat
nous avons déposé un ppr qui a été
adopté à l'unanimité
non messieurs de récession résolution a
raison de rappeler et donc les
socialistes ont fait leurs propositions
d'ailleurs elles sont annexe au rapport
dans le dans les propositions qui ont
été faites hier par gérard haché et les
choses que nous partageons des choses
quoi bein globalement sur une nouvelle
génération décentralisation je rappelle
que les socialistes nous avons été les
premiers à la faire avec françois
mitterrand occasion de faire donc c'est
dans notre adn dont le fait aussi que on
puisse clarifier les délais des
compétences entre l'état et les
collectivités que finalement les
colchiques d'une capacité d'autonomie
d'adaptation que soit l outre mer ou en
métropole dont il ya plein de points
communs
il ya des divergences donc mais moi je
trouve je trouve que quels sont les
divergences 6-2 vous deviez citer 1 1
point en particulier
je pense que nous nous sommes plus je
pense que notre
culturel est plus importante et je pense
qu'on va plus loin alors je peux vous
donner un point au sens où c'est plutôt
l'esprit
je crois que simple loin moi je peux
vous même dire que moi je vais encore
plus loin parce qu'à titre personnel je
suis pour des vrais parlements régionaux
avec députés régionaux plutôt que des
conseils régionaux comme au journal
espagnol nord parce que quand vous
donner cet exemple là ça veut dire que
c'est un devient une sorte de fédération
c'est parce que je dis je sais bien que
tout de suite on bloque le débat là
dessus moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui la
question qui nous est posée c'est
comment on rapproche le citoyen de la
décision et on le voit est donc abonnée
selon pour ça c'est le département comme
le dit gérard larcher
moi je pense qu'il ya plusieurs
plusieurs approches vous avez un couple
aujourd'hui qui existe qui est commune
intercours ça c'est un premier couple et
puis après vous avez un couple
département région donc ça il faut
regarder comment ça fonctionne
la question c'est pas ton l'échelon
c'est la question c'est qui fait quoi et
qui paye quoi je pense que c'est là
qu'il ya un souci 2 et dans tous les cas
après il faut rapprocher avec le citoyen
la décision le président de la
république a donné une interview à la
presse quotidienne régionale où il parle
de différenciation c'est le cas aussi de
gérard larcher vous vous êtes d'accord
il faut différencier selon les
territoires selon les régions ou les
départements
je pense qu'il faut que l'état pose un
cadre qui est de sa compétence propre ce
qui est de celles qui a peut être
transféré
qui paye comment et après comment tout
ça s'articule il ne faudrait pas que ce
soit une france à plusieurs vitesses
c'est là qu'il faut trouver le point
d'équilibré je voulais dire à mots parce
que il a fait l'interview près un public
très sympa enfin je vous invite à lire
l'interview parce que tous ceux qui
s'interrogent sur le virage social ou
écologique n'a pas ces on continue les
retraites extérieur à tous à tout même à
une grande conférence des territoires
mais le problème c'est que avec et avec
emmanuel con c'est toujours la même
histoire
il dit les choses il faut autre chose
prend un exemple simple sur la
décentralisation
celui qui a fait le pacte de cahors
qu'une fait une vraie recentralisation
financières et administratives et
politiques c est maintenant qu est ce
que vous pouvez vous retrouver quelque
part avec emmanuel macron sur ce sujet
de la décentralisation et d'un je ne
vous le dira lui la vision centralisée
il a dit je rappelle l'accord de cahors
c'est dorénavant les communes et des
collectivités
pas de progression de +10 2% vos
dépenses quoi qu'il arrive donc il a
redit l'ami la tutelle sur les communes
c'est celui qui a retiré la taxe
d'habitation qui a remis une tutelle
fiscale sur les communes de man dr keith
non si emmanuel macron changé je viens
discuter mais quand je prends les actes
c'est important on en 2020 ça fait trois
ans que les prisons sur la
décentralisation il a fait l'inversé
de ce que nous pensons nous les
socialistes ou ce que pense la chambre
des territoires à savoir le scénario
vous avez dit qu'ils décident paix c'est
exactement ce qu'a dit emmanuel macron
mais bien souvent l'état décidé c'est
les critiques paille mais moi ça me
saoule et une augmentation des dotations
non il ya deux choses et demain de
micron quand tu prends décision c'est
l'écossé qui pai pai pardon nous ce
qu'on dit c'est que effectivement
abandonnés si on transfère des
politiques publiques à des collectivités
quels que soit l'échelon ils focalisent
et les moyens de les mettre en place
dont pour cela il faut qu'elles aient
les moyens de leur politique
je rappelle que si on prend les communes
dorénavant avec la suppression la taxe
d'habitation on a retiré l'essentiel
mais ça a été entièrement compensées par
l'état est d'abord allé pas fini je
rappelle ses compensées à l'instant t
sauf qu'ensuite les coachs et elle
continue à avoir des dépenses
je prends un exemple très simple vous
êtes dans une commune vous développez un
quartier que c'était un nouveau quartier
bon sauf que ça c'est plus intégrée dans
la compensation ça n'existe pas mais
dans ce quartier là il faut développer
des actions publiques une école des
pôles culturels des pôles de santé qui
les payent les communes sans argent
supplémentaire de l'état russe c'est une
mécanique un peu folle la 7h été mal en
quelques mots gérard larcher d'hier
notre pays se fracturent vous les voyez
vous ces fractures vous en france la
première fracture c'est la question de
social aujourd'hui il ya cette question
sociale mais je vous dis un autre
exemple est donc moi je vois dans la loi
ce parce que dans la loi j'avais ces
mini france à la fois vous avez des
territoires ruraux et très urbain et moi
je vois à l'aide les fractures mais je
prends un exemple sur l'éducation en
france quand vous avez vous aiderez
l'étude pisa puis l'étude du ministère
les différences des inégalités à la
naissance à lente quand vous rentrez à
l'école sont au mieux au mieux maintenu
à la sortie dont ce qui est pour nous
dans notre idéal républicain
moi je suis républicain c'est l'école
qui permet l'émancipation
on voit que l'école globalement bloque
la société française d exception à la
règle n'est sûr mais elle bloque c'est
un échec
et donc là c'est pas un exemple de
fracture la question sociale aujourd'hui
les gens de plus en plus riche des ans
de plus en plus pauvres et puis le
sentiment que la république n'est plus
là dire quand vous êtes pour la public
vous dit
la pluie qui permet d'avancer en termes
de services en termes d'écoles the lady
entame transport et il ya deux
sentiments de france à plusieurs
vitesses aller au terme de cette
émission avec la mission d'information
sénatoriale sur les mains
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à partir du 1er septembre la police ne
pourra plus utiliser la technique dite
de la clé d'étranglement pourquoi
christophe castaner at il décidé d'y
mettre fin quelles techniques de
substitution pour les forces de l'ordre
le directeur général de la police
étaient entendus au sénat jérôme rabin
revient sur les moments forts de cette
audition il a la délicate mission de
protéger les policiers qu'il dirige
mais aussi de rendre des comptes au
ministère de l'intérieur
le directeur général de la police
nationale assume donc ses dernières
décisions devant la mission
d'information du sénat
oui c'est lui qui a proposé à christophe
castaner d'arrêter l'apprentissage de la
technique dite d'étranglement qui ne
sera donc plus enseignée en école de
police
je suis à l'origine de la proposition
que j'ai faite au ministre de
l'intérieur de d'abandonner cette
technique qui est très impactante pour
celle ou celui qui la subit
et bien sûr aussi très utile pour celle
ou celui qui la met en oeuvre
simplement quand elle est mal maîtrisée
elle peut avoir des conséquences
importantes et donc ma responsabilité ça
n'est pas d'exposer les personnels dont
j'ai la responsabilité sur le terrain
que ce soit en termes de sécurité
physique ou de sécurité juridique
mais pour les sénateurs il ya sans doute
eu de la précipitation dans cette
décision
comme l'expliquent le président de la
mission d'information philippe bas ce
qui suscite une certaine interrogation
aujourd'hui c'est que on décide
d'interrompre la formation
à cette technique mais qu'on n'a pas
encore véritablement l'alternative or il
faut que force reste toujours à la loi
un argumentaire qui reprend les plaintes
des syndicats de policiers qui
s'inquiètent de l'abandon de ces
techniques d'interpellation
c'est une des raisons de leur
manifestation récente mais frédéric
veaux tient à les rassurer
il a rappelé aux sénateurs que si la
technique n'est plus enseignée elle peut
encore être utilisé dans la tente d'une
technique de remplacement pour laquelle
les fonctionnaires de police devront
être formés
rachid tu es mal fin de la clé
d'étranglement vous saluer ce choix de
christophe castaner c'est très compliqué
parce que dit on le voit dans votre
reportage encore une fois on voit un
gouvernement qui est dans la
précipitation puisque on annonce la fin
de cette clé très bien mais le temps il
n'y a pas de solution poser à la place
donc en fait moi je pense qu'il faut se
mettre les choses très clairement un
il faut rappeler que les forces de
police c'est une c'est une force de
police républicaine il faut cela le rôle
des policiers gendarmes et autres pays
et quand il ya des actes individuels qui
pose problème
que ce soit sur les des violences ou des
propos racistes à commune il faut
sanctionner duroux et il faut dire que
en même temps il ya un malaise des
policiers ont entrepris des forces de
police mais est ce que vous dites quand
même sur la clé d'étranglement c'est on
la maintient non non moi je vous dis pas
ça tant qu'il ya pas d'indiquer que
cette qui est sur l'allée cette
question-là l'est posée depuis longtemps
non on parle d'art cours d'un retour aux
taux teaser versements mais cette
théorie oui mais on l'a enlevé parce que
c'était dangereux on va enlever la crise
est vraiment parce que c'est dangereux
c'est un peu absurde c'est un peu le
sérieux qu'on serait le seul payant au
monde à ne pas savoir comment
appréhender une personne ça n'est pas
sérieux
dire que monsieur k salaire depuis trois
ans il a découvert que le loup ti et
pistolet avec l'électricité c'était
problématique de taser pardon merci et
la clé s'est posé problème qu'est ce
qu'on fait depuis qu'est ce qu'il fait
depuis trois ans ce malaise là il existe
déjà il était déjà réalisée le 10 on est
désarmé face à des délinquants est donc
pris
la question qui est posée c'est pourquoi
le ministère n'a elle pas depuis à
travers d'autres solutions interactives
et former les policiers parce
qu'aujourd'hui ce que réclament les
policiers c'est des moyens pour agir
vraiment ce qu'ils n'ont pas donc oui
encore une fois ça normalement qu'il
fait un effet d'annonce puis qui revient
pas en arrière ça en sachant pas comment
faire parce que il annonce qu'il le
retire pour
tendre mais tant qu'il n'y a pas d'autre
chose on le maintient donc tout ça n'est
pas sérieux
moi je pense que si il ya aujourd'hui on
le voit dans les études d'opinion
souvent avec entre la police notamment
la jeunesse c'est extrêmement grave
donc je pense qu'il faut pas les opposer
il faut dire que la jeunesse peut vivre
sa vie mais les forces de police sont là
pour nous protéger et donc ça veut dire
qu'un événement de responsable sérieux
qu'on décision en lien avec les uns les
autres et planifiée dans le temps
aujourd'hui on voit bien que s'ils ne
sont pas sérieux et ça crée encore une
fois des troupes dans l'autre c'est ça
interroge en tout cas le recours à la
force par les autorités publiques adama
traoré la fère s'est passé dans votre
département vous soutenez vous comprenez
les manifestations organisées à l'appel
de la famille moi ce que je dis
simplement c'est que quand au bout de
quatre années ne sont toujours pas
expliqué comment un individu en l'espèce
adama traoré est décédé dans une
gendarmerie
ça pose problème et ça pose question je
crois qu aussi dès le début on avait la
réponse
il ya eu déjà quatre expertises
contradictoires et si le gouvernement je
crois avait été un peu plus sérieux je
pense qu'ils n'en seraient pas là vous
demander la démission de christophe
cattin logement depuis démission ce que
je note c'est que ça fait quatre ans que
personne c'est ce qui s'est passé je
serais vous verrez après avoir soulevé
le débat sur plus largement parce que
d'évoquer la question du racisme et
discrimination
on a un débat mais je crois que vous
n'êtes pas beaucoup dans ma vie ça c'est
une vraie question par contre pour le
coup je vois pas de la fin de ma théorie
mais la question du racisme et de la
lutte contre et discrétion entre pays
c'est un vrai sujet après cela je crois
que la police mais le racisme vie dans
toute la société est d'ailleurs les
études défenseur enfin les études du
défenseur droit le démontrent les
mouettes d'ailleurs je dis à ma famille
politique que c'est un vrai sujet qu'il
faut reprendre accord une question
puisqu'on a appris la démission de
d'edouard philippe et son gouvernement y
avait nécessité pour vous de changer de
gouvernement de donner un nouvel élan à
la majorité souvent après élection
municipale perdue
et là c'est une défaite c'est une
débâcle jamais impertinent parti au
gouvernement n'a perdu autant que la
plus qu'en marche le week-end dernier
il ya un changement mais une fois qu'on
aura passé pour celles et ceux qui sont
dans leur téléphone attendent
et puis vous aurez vous à faire quelques
tribus en faisant un tel niveau il
affectera ça très sympa
la question c'est quelle politique et
quand je lis interview du présent un
public
hier dans la presse régionale je ne vois
pas de changement de politique au
contraire je crois qu'il va continuer
vers toujours plus à droite toujours
plus de libéralisme et je crois que ça
se terminera mal pour cette majorité
d'ailleurs et je le dis il faut
maintenir les élections parce que quand
on dit aux français
il faut venir plus participer la
première chose qu'on ne fait pas c'est
de changer les élections je rappelle
parce que le prince lui qui soit décalé
sections départementales et rejet d'un
prévu dans neuf mois
elle n'en serais pas il confirme qu'il
renonce à décaler les élections
départementales et régionales
oui mais ça enfin moi j'attendrais
devoir parce que comme il a dû aux
parlementaires qu'ils le feraient s'ils
renonçaient déjà en deux jours en trois
jours un changement pied ce sera le laf
a remercié la chine était mal merci
brigitte à ce titre on y trouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de parlement hebdo
[Musique]